so we're now 20 months into the coven 19
pandemic we're still fighting it very
much so we thought now as we're
gathering for thanksgiving get a bit of
a report card see where things stand and
joining us this morning the dean of
medicine over at unlv uh dr mark khan dr
good to see you in person for a change
nice to see you john good to see you so
let's first of all get to where we are
right now um
20 months as we mentioned cases are for
the most part going down certainly down
from the peak where do we stand here in
southern nevada in the fight against the
pandemic so we're doing just okay um we
have you know somewhere just under 60
percent of our population vaccinated
with at least two doses uh as you know
we have recommendations now for booster
vaccines as well
you know we need to get more people
vaccinated and we need to continue with
the social distancing that's really
going to be very important and you know
when you walk down the strip at night
there's just not enough people wearing
masks quite frankly and we're we're not
over it yet so we can't forget those
public health
methods you know you mentioned walking
on the las vegas strip anywhere around
town uh it seems as though the effort to
social distance and the effort to wear
masks has has relaxed for for a lot of
the public whether it's through fatigue
or just indifference
on a public health basis what can be
done to combat that is it a matter of
putting more restrictions in place
potentially
you know restrictions are only going to
be so good because people still have to
follow the recommendations i think you
know just some
public education you know we're getting
close if people practice social
distancing
if people practice social
distancing for perhaps another six
months i think we could really say that
we're on the other side of this but we
can't let our guard down can't let our
guard down
families are about to gather for
thanksgiving obviously and whether
they're coming in from out of town or
they're just here in the valley all
meeting for some place for dinner what
are some just simple things that people
need to remember as they're sitting down
at the table together uh when it comes
to staying safe during the pandemic
again it depends if people are
vaccinated or not so
even for vaccinated people it's going to
be important wash your hands right i
think that minimizing social contact is
still important
certainly if people aren't vaccinated
they're safer away from
others so that they don't either catch
nor transmit the disease so it really
depends you know we had a very difficult
thanksgiving last year um you know when
we were in the thick of covet and hadn't
had an available vaccine yet
now that people are vaccinated i think
we can loosen up some of those
requirements but for the unvaccinated i
think there's they still need to be very
cautious
obviously we know that children as young
as five can get a version of the
coronavirus vaccines the boosters are
now available for for all adults uh here
in southern nevada we've both been vaxed
and boosted and whatnot one question
i've always had is
you know again this is i guess
pre-booster can you just get the vaccine
twice is there something in the
the creation of the vaccine that would
prevent someone from instead of getting
the booster just getting the two doses
all over again so john you know the
booster for pfizer is just the regular
vaccine
for moderna it's a half dose so
essentially that's exactly what you're
doing the booster right now isn't
anything special
as we get more variants of the virus
this mrna technology makes it much
easier to create vaccines for some of
the mutated viruses we don't have them
commercially available yet but they're
being studied it's interesting i think a
lot of folks when we talk about vaccine
hesitancy they don't trust how fast the
vaccine was created how fast it's been
approved by the fda and so forth and how
fast the public has been
receiving it pregnant women for example
how do you
respond to those who have either those
hesitancies over the vaccine or just
don't trust it at all
so so look you know the technology
behind the mrna vaccines really goes
back to about 1985
at my alma mater at the university of
pennsylvania the technology has been
developed since then
we have had other mrna vaccines for
things like ebola etc that haven't been
fda approved because we don't have ebola
in this country so this was really a
derivation of an existing technology and
you know the proof's in the pudding with
billions of doses of vaccine given now
this is a safe and effective vaccine
is are we at a point now where
it's almost like the flu where it's not
a matter of beating the coronavirus
pandemic but we just sort of learned to
live with a version of covid19
so you know i hope that if we get enough
people vaccinated we're going to see a
lot less of this disease
coronaviruses naturally circulate
through the population they're
responsible for common colds and there's
even a theory perhaps that the common
colds that we get every year
previously perhaps were endemic and
epidemic in the population so i think
we're going to be living with
with a form of the cova virus i think we
just all hope that it's not as lethal
and not as deadly
let's get to some of your questions we
have some questions we'd asked the
public to to submit their questions for
you as we knew we were going to be on
here's a question from stu who says he
got the single dose j j vaccine back in
april trying to find out whether or not
the pfizer or moderna vaccine gives
higher immune response
for a booster i know when i got my
booster i got the pfizer booster even
though i got the modern initial vaccine
and essentially you could mix and match
yeah i think that you're right john you
can really mix and match there is some
data that suggests that if you got the
pfizer vaccine and you boost with
moderna there may be a more robust
immune response so it's certainly not
wrong to do that but i don't think we
have the data really comparing
head-to-head to say one way is better
than another what is known is people
who've been vaccinated need to get a
booster shot
lily asks this question we were talking
about social distancing and wearing
masks
are face shields an alternative to a
mask i think we're referencing some of
the clear shields maybe you see
around town
does that have the same level of
protection
so
you know
when you wear a mask you do two things
firstly you protect others from you
potentially infecting them and secondly
there's some protection to the mass
wearer from getting infected with
antivirus but corona is what we're
talking about the problem with face
shields is they don't really occlude the
mouth and nose so there's still air and
potential for particles to get around
the shield so shields are not as good as
masks
probably better than nothing but really
i think folks should wear a mask and i
should mention you and i aren't wearing
a mask but we've both been vaccinated
and boosted and we're six feet apart so
normally we'd be wearing masks as well
yeah we wear masks in in the studio as
well
um
final question i believe comes from dj
who talks about why
asks why masks are mandatory indoors
everywhere except for restaurants a
place where we're all constantly opening
our mouths leaving saliva on the rims of
glasses utensils
she knows they need to make money too
just curious i think that goes back to
the idea that we were talking about
before of
some of the regulations that are still
in place is there a is it a bit um
confusing i think for some members of
the public to see
what's allowed and what's not allowed
i don't know how to respond to that but
it there's some sort of confusion i
think some among some of the public yeah
i think you know there's science and
there's public perception
the science would suggest that we should
be wearing mass as much as possible
right that's how we're going to prevent
transmission of the virus but then
there's a practical reality you can't
eat and drink through a mask right so
when you're in a restaurant you know you
still have to lift the mask to eat and
drink
the amount of time that you keep the
mask on though is is really going to
determine how good the protection
actually is
when you're outside because you're not
in an enclosed space
there is more area for
particles to dissipate if you will so
you're not going to get as high a
concentration and that's why
mass don't have to be worn outdoors
again though that's public perception
not science the science suggests that
the way to prevent transmission of covid
and other viral infections is through
social distancing mass hand washing etc
and one of the interesting things is you
know we had a very very light flu season
last year and that's because of social
distancing so in fact it works
well dr khan good to see you once again
good to see you in person and have a
happy thanksgiving happy thanksgiving
thank you for your time appreciate it
folks get vaccinated